aux candidats précisément comptez vous
interdire totalement la publicité sur le
tabac sur l'alcool sur les vitesses
excessives annoncé par certaines marques
automobiles question posée par
d'éminents professeurs de métier et nos
deux candidats ont répondu bien sûr
aussi bien françois mitterrand que
jacques chirac alors jean daniel
flaysakier a lu attentivement toutes ces
réponses les fabricants de cigarettes
qui ne mégote pas sur la publicité des
brasseurs prêt à tout pour faire mousser
leur bière et des constructeurs qui
annonce des vitesses sur circuit bien
sûr capable de décoiffer tous les radars
en bout de course cela fait cent mille
morts par an beaucoup trop pour les
professeurs hirsch du ghana go et du
bois qui ont décidé d'adresser à chacun
des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle une lettre il demande à
ses candidats s'il serait d'accord pour
interdire toute publicité pour l'alcool
la vitesse et le tabac pour le tabac
françois mitterrand se dit favorable à
l'interdiction totale de toute publicité
dans les médias en france et en europe
jacques chirac lui souhaite que soient
appliqués enfin la loi veil votre paix
en 1976
pas d'interdiction totale pour le moment
mais il n'est pas ce qu'ils n'ont plus
une interdiction visant tout le marché
commun en ce qui concerne l'alcool
jacques chirac s'en tient aux termes de
la loi votée en juillet 87 et qui
réglemente la publicité en particulier
en l'interdisant sur les chaînes de
télévision françois mitterrand feluy
étendre cette interdiction à la radio et
aux salles de cinéma pour toutes les
boissons alcoolisées y compris la bière
en ce qui concerne la mention de
vitesses illégales dans les publicités
les deux candidats préfèrent la
concertation avec les constructeurs
ni l'un ni l'autre n'en visage dans
l'immédiat d'interdire de telles
publicités sur le territoire français
les français sont particulièrement ce
sont les premiers concernés en europe
des communautés européennes par les
problèmes de comportement dangereux pour
la santé
et donc il me semble que et c'était le
sens de notre appel de notre
interpellation il me semble que les
hommes politiques vont prendre en compte
ces propositions et ces interpellations
le souhait de ses médecins et donc que
l'on s'intéresse autant à la santé des
français qu'à celle du franc il rappelle
en outre que ces fléaux coûte beaucoup
plus cher à la société qui nous
censée rapporter à coups de taxes
oisienne